[Applauso]
[Musica]
vorrei condurvi al momento più
importante della vostra vita
sapete quello per cui avete lavorato
sognato sperato lavorato ancora può
essere una discussione di tesi può
essere la riunione più importante può
essere qualcosa che veramente per voi ha
fatto e farà la differenza
siete pronti il vostro abito l'avete
scelto con cura comodo però anche deve
rappresentarvi e poi il vostro discorso
avete ripetuto più volte ci siete
e quindi buonasera sono chiara comastri
e poi via avete con voi tutte le persone
che vi hanno sostenuto sentite la
felicità e la responsabilità di questo e
vi chiamano è il vostro momento
bene vi alzate
ok la parola non esce ok
sorridi prendi tempo è ok però penso a
dio cosa iniziano a pensare di me ok ok
quali sono i vostri pensieri in quel
momento quali sono le emozioni che avete
in quel momento
cosa pensano di voi
oddio iniziate ad avere la sensazione di
spazio che si stringe addosso a voi
ok oggi parliamo di balbuzie
ma quanti di voi si sono riconosciuti in
questa descrizione o quanti di voi hanno
osservato altre persone a cui è accaduto
la balbuzie sapete colpisce il 45 per
cento della popolazione a livello
mondiale
quindi vuol dire che su un teatro come
questo di 900 persone circa 40 persone
fra voi possono soffrire di balbuzie
ma quanti di voi si sono riconosciuti in
quello che ho portato adesso come
esempio
e allora balbuzie non solo non solo
perché in realtà il meccanismo è uguale
per tutti il meccanismo qual è
dove sono andati i vostri pensieri dove
andate alla vostra attenzione sul vostro
corpo che non respira sul vostro cuore
che batte troppo sulla voce che trema e
quindi quanto avete riportato le
attenzioni su voi stessi
questo è il meccanismo di cui parliamo
oggi che è anche quello di chi balbetta
anche quindi interessante perché
iniziamo a comprendere che in realtà il
meccanismo se interno è qualcosa che può
colpire molte più persone di quello che
noi pensiamo sapete la balbuzie spesso
viene interpretato come un disturbo di
linguaggio oppure si pensa che sia
qualcosa di genetico oppure si pensa che
colpisca solo quando c'è ansia
sono tantissime le idee che ci sono
rispetto alla valducci forse troppo e
questo ce la dice lunga
in realtà quello che vorrei portarvi
oggi è la semplicità del meccanismo che
colpisce tutte le persone che tendono ad
avere difficoltà nella relazione con
l'altro perché sapete è proprio un
meccanismo che a che fare con l'altro
come mai spesso quando noi siamo lì
nella nostra cameretta da soli a
ripetere qualcosa di importante
un'interrogazione un esame una riunione
importante siamo perfetti meravigliosi e
appena abbiamo gli occhi di un'altra
persona che ci guardano iniziamo a
vacillare più persone che ci guardano e
iniziano a vacillare
allora questo il meccanismo che dobbiamo
trasformare e scopriremo adesso che la
risposta in realtà è tornare proprio
sull'altro invece che rimanere
imbrigliati noi stessi e tornare
sull'alto rimanere lì con l'attenzione
l'intenzione completamente questa è la
risposta
sapete la balbuzie e davvero un
meccanismo interno la valbusa è qualcosa
che io percepiscono il mio pensiero che
tu non potrai mai scoprire cosa che
senti tu che ascolti me che balbetta tu
senti l'effetto che produce la
percezione del blocco
vi faccio un esempio devo dire una frase
semplicissima come domani vado al mare
allora iniziò a parlare domani vado al e
sento so che lei mary mare sarà
inceppata in mente non articolo male non
pronuncio male so
nel mio pensiero che la m di mare sarà
inceppata
questa è la balbuzie da quando io sento
che quella emancipata devo trovare una
soluzione e allora cosa succede domani
va dal mamma mamma mamma mamma mamma
mamma re rimbalzo fino a che sento il
via libera oppure inizia usare il corpo
lo forzo domani vado al mare oppure
oppure altro respiro per cercare di
avere una via d'uscita
domani vado all
mare mare oppure domani vado al die dove
siamo andati alla settimana scorsa con
gli amici sulla spiaggia a al mare fa in
modo che qualcuno te lo dica ma capito
qual è il meccanismo comune la
percezione della m nei tuoi pensieri
quella la fregatura quella è la balbuzie
e tu chi ascolti non lo senti cos'è che
senti tu senti il meglio che la persona
sta facendo per ottenere una soluzione
che percepisci la soluzione che è
un'alterazione certo c'è una fatica nel
parlare c'è una dis fluence in quel
linguaggio ma tu senti la soluzione to
percepisci il meglio che può fare la
persona per risolvere sarà la balbuzie
non percepisci cos'è il blocco la
persona dentro di sé lo percepisce e
allora torniamo al fatto che siamo
dentro di noi
accidenti è quindi la soluzione è
l'altro sapete noi durante i corsi che
teniamo per risolvere questo tipo di
difficoltà
lavoriamo tanto su gigi e marta gigi
sono io e marta sei tu
marta sei tu marta sei tu marta sei tu
marta sei tu l'altro è marta e allora
davvero cosa succede quando siamo in
difficoltà e come invece dobbiamo
rimanere quando sentiamo difficoltà devo
rimanere in apertura e con la voglia di
ascoltarti e di portare il messaggio
veramente a te vi chiedo quindi di
giocare con me adesso di mettervi seduti
sulle sedie un po in punta se avete un
po sul bordo e di poggiare bene i piedi
in modo che possiamo sperimentare questo
piccolo gioco tutti insieme
vi chiedo di posizionarvi ben vestito di
sentire bene comodità due piedi poggiati
e vi chiedo di chiudere gli occhi
ti chiedo di percepire bene il vostro
corpo
la sensazione dei fieri che poggiano e
della forma che le vostre gambe hanno
portate la schiena verso l'alto e aprite
le spalle e prendete spazio
[Musica]
il diesel rilassato sorride
e respirate
gustatevi la sensazione del vostro
respiro comodo
vi chiedo adesso di respirare nel cuore
e percepite una bolla che il vostro
spazio
quanto spazio occupa realtà questa
voglia
allora provate a
percepire una persona alla vostra destra
emana calore che forma
e allora allargata e la bolla è andata
ad abbracciare anche l'altra persona con
voi e poi fate lo stesso con una persona
a sinistra e gustatevi proprio questa
sensazione di bolla che si allarga e
ancora davanti a voi allargate davanti a
voi e sentite che lavora cambia forma
e iniziata adesso a renderli proprio
conto che all'interno di essa ci sono
altre bolle che si muovono il vostro
spazio diventa vivo vibrante grazie ad
altre persone per sono lì con voi in
questo momento e ha senso allargato e la
bolla respirate
percepite fino a dove potete arrivare
anche all'interno di questo teatro
arrivate fin qua al palco portatile con
voi percepite bolle che si intersecano e
quanto potete andare anche al di fuori
di questo teatro giocate con la fantasia
allargata allargate percepite gli altri
all'interno del vostro spazio come vi
rendono più comodo di vostro stare lì
adesso
voi al centro di questo spazio io sono
qui io sono qui radicate vc dentro e
respirate allargata questa bolla giocate
giocate
potete andare fino a casa vostra c'è
qualcuno a casa che potete fare il
solletico
fino a dove potete abbracciare andate
andate andate e percepita un aumento di
più comodi tanto dove sentite pensioni
allentate respirate gustatevi la
sensazione di essere con l'altro e
percepite la comodità e la maggiore
forza
[Musica]
vi chiedo di avere gli occhi
e cercate di
percepire l'atmosfera in questo teatro o
di guardarvi cercatevi con lo sguardo
sorridete la sensazione che grazie a te
la mia comunicazione diventa speciale
sulla mia comunicazione la sento solo io
come fa essere speciale grazie a te che
prende forma allora per me è importante
che voi prendiate proprio il punto di
vista che tutto è allenabile tutto e
alle nobile anche la comodità che si può
avere nella relazione con l'altro la mia
certezza è che la balbuzie si risolve
sapete
fino a qualche anno fa il mio modo di
presentarmi era questo allora allora
dunque allora allora allora sono chiara
comastri
ho 43 anni e vi avrei fatto tutto il mio
discorso oggi in questo modo la balbuzie
si risolve ci vuole un metodo uno sforzo
preciso ma davvero tutto è allenabile
tutto l'altro è sempre la risposta è
inutile continuare a cercare risposte
dentro di sé l'altro ti dà la risposta
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]